in regards to working out right in
training for you know selection and by
selection you mean
I mean Special Forces or Ranger or SEAL
selection yeah that's what they're
talking about here yeah so chuckle what
do you think of rucking as fitness
versus just train up so for people that
don't know what rocking is rocking is
putting a backpack on a rucksack with a
bunch of weight in it and walking long
distances and and to be honest with you
you really aren't jogging you know
you're really going at a pretty good
pace when you're doing it and that's it
as far as rucking that's what it is
because because in the military mm-hmm
they can bring the pain with rock back
marches forced Road marches is what
they're called yeah you'd be rocking all
up in you you'll be rocking so you don't
want to be rocking and and so you know
you'll do 20-mile forest road march
which is just you're on the road with a
50 pound pack just marching yeah and so
the thing is like anything else if you
want to get good at it you got to do it
right so if you want to get good at
people ask me like how do you don't get
we're gonna get it going to pull ups you
know how do you get good at pull-ups and
do pull-ups how do you get good at
running run how do you get it swimming
so I'm mmm oh you want to know how to
get good at jiu-jitsu dude you Jitsu you
know get on the mat and do jiu-jitsu a
bunch you know and if you want to get
good at rockin at a hump in a rock
carrying weight over long distances Rock
because there's all kinds of little
things got to get used to your feet got
to get prepared you're gonna get weird
muscles your back's gotta get stronger
you get you know calluses all over your
feet it takes a special type of fitness
regimen to get used to and ready for
long rock marches and the special
fitness regimen is rocking and lots of
it so if you want to eventually you can
augment that you know you can start
doing squats you can start doing sprints
and that'll help you you know that's
fine but
the foundation of the preparation for
rock humping should be rock humping and
that's what's gonna make you good at it
so did you do that I did I did
and rucking for me actually oddly enough
is something that I was almost good at
no and it's weird because I wasn't the
fastest sprinter and I wasn't the best
long-distance runner which boy does that
make makes you a loser right you can't
win a sprint and you can't run a
long-distance run what's wrong with you
yeah you're kind of in the middle that I
was in the middle and what I realized
was that was good for carried a rucksack
yeah and I got used to it too because I
was a radio man so you always had always
had a carrier frickin radio you know
thirty pound radio with water and
batteries and you're just it's always
heavy you're just sucking it up and so I
got used to it I suppose it was Matt
more than anything else you're like um
you've seen the movie tremors no they
gave me Trevor's right well there's a
time at the end they're like man we need
to we need to go to those mountains for
those you know to avoid the underground
worms and they were like hey we could
take the cat and he's like hey it's it's
low you know the cat is a big you know
the Bobcat I'd actually know what a
Bobcat is I'm not sure I know what
underground world that's something
completely different but their bet so
they took the Caddy and the guy the guy
was like no we can't take the cat slower
than hell and he's like it doesn't mean
it can carry a tunnel you know it was he
was like you you're like the cat so they
hooked up this big trailer which is the
rock in your chest and you know and they
didn't they drove everybody um you know
to the mountain well the day planner do
you walk no they're trapped on on roofs
on a rooftop and they're like we're all
gonna starve up here we got to make it
to the mountains it's like nine miles
okay like how are we gonna get there we
can't you know we can't run they're
gonna get us we can't you know so we'll
get the cat God they were like oh it's
too slow but they're Lincoln yeah but it
can carry this big trailer yeah you know
and I used to say that in the SEAL Teams
and I my opinion was it was better to be
built like a four by four then like a
Porsche
yeah when it was better to be it just
because you got to carry weight around
durable you know what would you rather
have working on a farm ford f350 or a
Porsche yeah I mean a Porsche is cool
for the track when everything's all
lined up and dialed the way it's
supposed to be you get any kind of
terrain going on you want that floor
before and he want it bad and so that's
why you know the seals the seals guys
that were kind of more a 4x4 mm than a
Porsche yes it would be a better in the
field in the real seal situations yeah
you know the read the actual because the
thing about that's that's it's a
misconception about the SEAL Teams is
you know you see guys running on the
beach and you see you guys swimming in
the ocean and they never are carrying
anything yeah that's just complete lie
because every time you do anything in
the SEAL Teams you're caring at all the
weight with you yeah
and so you got to be built like a 4x4
and not like a Porsche yeah yeah make
sense so yeah you'd weigh rather someone
like you then some sprinter who can run
like a 4 to 40 but then he puts them you
know something sprinters actually you
know what you you just want somebody
that's durable yeah
durable is the word yeah and if they're
great athlete and they can have a
awesome 40 time or they can run a
marathon but they're just durable it's
awesome yeah ok I'm not trying to put
parameters around the guys sure because
there's guys there was a guy when I was
a team too and he was a guy I actually
went through buds with and he was he's
he's kind of a short guy and he was kind
of had a odd the body shape and so he
kind of looked he kind of had almost
like a little pudgy belly and he just
was one of those guys and the funny
thing is he could run faster than me and
he could bench more than me he had no
kidding it was awesome I love that yeah
he's an awesome guy awesome guy I said
you know that's cool people say that
about him because he's
but short and a little bit pouty looking
I'm like he can he can actually bench
more than me and he can run fast beating
all the runs so let's just be quiet yeah